si on prend justement des grands
champions français mondialisé dans le
luxe un super grand champion qui
s'appelle lvmh lvmh ou est-ce qu'ils
ouvrent des ateliers aujourd'hui en
france
c'est à châteauroux et issoudun dans
l'indre c'est dans des endroits
justement qui sont pas des métropoles
donc on peut aussi faire des choses sur
ce tissu économique de ces villes
moyennes de ces villes qui ont un
potentiel et puis lé sur lesquels on vit
bien où il ya moins d'absentéisme où il
ya une qualité de vie qui fait que les
gens ne t'a pas trois heures de voiture
ou de métro de trappes pour aller au
travail
donc il va me répondre que celle ceo qui
décide de changer le bas c'est pas le
bas qui a la capacité de changer oui
mais c'est dommage de vous la clé dit
venez chez moi parce que voilà on y
travaille bien et on est encore mieux
que vélib qui se vend sur le marché
international en vie et l'art et non non
mais enfin voilà là on touche un vrai
point de divergence dire que bon jusqu'à
maintenant ont été globalement d'accord
sur pas mal de choses
moi je considère que les collectivités
locales n'ont pas à se vendre pour
attirer les investisseurs et que on
devrait avoir de la régulation politique
et que on devra avoir des mécanismes qui
permettent de relocaliser l'économie
autrement que en s'auto régulièrement
dans les investissements et l armory aux
dirigeants il faut dire à monsieur
arnaud voilà nous etat alors la datar
n'existe plus mais on va vous dire
monsieur vous pouvez installer votre
atelier à tel endroit tel endroit moi je
trouve que c'est plus sain de que le
maire d'issoudun et le maire de
châteauroux disent écoutez moi j'ai une
super nombre d'entreprises venez chez
moi on y bosse bien
c'est aussi la liberté et puis c et puis
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne c'est
comme ça qu'on met en fait les
territoires en concurrence et que
et les collectivités cherchent à ce
qu'on fait sony datar qui disent on va
implanter les ateliers à tel ou tel
endroit avoir avoir une politique
d'aménagement du territoire ça veut dire
avoir une politique d'ensemble sur des
grandes filières économiques est
confronté ça avec une réalité locale
[Musique]